I am happy. I like making videos for you guys. You guys are the best,
but I've got to call this trend out less, less,
more. Here's my version of that fed. Less, less,
and now more. Ooh, wait, wait, wait.
This is not going to be video chaos.
Let me Orient you first. These beauties animated.
It takes on language and communication.
These take like 20 plus hours per minute of finished footage,
so please enjoy no pressure but enjoy them in eavesdropping traveler,
each vineyard takes a charming,
quirky look at a destination through its local language. I take pictures,
create art, and even write music for these. Finally,
what began his plans for behind the sous take is putting into its own series a
series that's more direct, a bit villagey and ties in a random topic each time.
There's still the old stuff last year is questions about human language and even
older technical lessons aren't getting updated, but they're still around.
All right. Have at it. See when the videos.